but I actually doing it's not gonna
crash right god dammit
good thing I'm poor so I'll steal it I
guess that did that sounded worse than I
wanted it to I have nothing to say about
socioeconomic status I'm just trying to
play a game let's get some relaxing
orchestrate classical music going hmmm
this is much better symphony for my my
my Entrail bite bite I'm gonna destroy
this [ __ ] fly I don't give a f---
raver
oh I've never been so angry in my life
what Oh God possess okay he's talking
about there
okay Matt preemptively censor this one
just bring it in bring it in bigger
bigger bigger bigger bigger okay little
more a little more
stop good enough yep that was exactly
what it should have been why another one
another one another one another one
another one
Oh buttercup from The Hunger Games
no I was thinking of uh princess
Jasmine's Tiger drum I have this like
striped clothing
Green Bay Packer [ __ ] oh geez what a
load of crap
oh oh there we go that's more like it
stupid [ __ ] these are literal ass oh
yeah rhythmic [ __ ]
oh you rhythmic [ __ ] no you dressed up
for me you fun guys hello
like that's below the poverty line
that's why issues that's no cop comments
YouTube god dammit comments comments
come back here stop no I really want to
see how many people press the button
I've got a lot really ah now I look like
an [ __ ] but it's probably really good
cake I'm sorry all my fans in Detroit
please join everyone still talking about
politics in the comments below to tell
me how bad I am which is rather be 4
feet tall or be 10 feet tall hey wait a
minute I'm four foot two I don't think
you'd I'd rather be four foot oh gosh oh
no how horrible I'd be 10 feet III meant
to click the foot
I'd rather just get it out of the way
and watch it and then move on that does
not mean I'm no brownie I don't wanna
know in the comments section know
there's word everyone announces to their
entire families markiplier would rather
punch a baby because the kid would
rather punch in table no why do I feel
bad I blew up Detroit in the last one
that's not the proper way to hold a
Mario contend no control you silly Billy
I'll have to teach you how to play
properly later thanks for watching all
of the videos in this compilation are
available in the description so check
them out and if you'd like to see more
in the future please leave a like to let
me know if you enjoyed this video and
you'd like to see more on a daily basis
please subscribe today or if you're
already subscribed share this video with
a friend thanks again for watching and
I'll see you in the next video bye bye